eight rubber stamps cost 9.28
which equation would help determine the
cost of 11 rubber stamps
so let's just set a variable here for
the cost of 11 rubber stamps let's call
that let's call that x is equal to the
cost
of 11
11
stamps
and there's
a bunch of ways to set up this
proportion to set up this equation you
could say you could say that eight eight
relates so eight stamps let me write so
eight stamps
relates to the cost of eight stamps
relates to the cost of eight stamps
nine dollars twenty eight just as 11
stamps just as 11 stamps
11 stamps relate to the cost of 11
stamps relate to the cost of 11 stamps
so this would be one legitimate equation
the number of stamps to the cost of
stamps number of stamps to the cost of
the stamps another way you could do it
you could say
eight
stamps
to 11 stamps would be equal to the cost
of 8 stamps which is
9.28 to the cost of
11 stamps to the cost of 11 stamps so
this is another actually equivalent
equation you can do algebraic operations
to get from to get from one to the other
the other options is that you can flip
the numerator and the denominator of
both you essentially can take you can
take the reciprocal of both sides so
this is also you could rewrite this as
this one over here you could say nine
dollars and 28 is to eight
as
x
is to eleven i've just flipped both
sides
or you could flip both sides of this
eleven is 8 as x is to 9.28
and obviously any of these you can flip
the equal sign you can say x over 9.28
is the same thing as 11 over 8.